[Musique]
la Namibie et l'Afrique du Sud sont les
pays invités d'honneur du Grand 20
décembre 2023 qui se déroulera les 19 et
20 décembre au Musée historique de
Villelle un programme riche qui mèle
conférences visite guidé et
concert cette année nous avons l'honneur
et la chance de pouvoir accueillir une
délégation de Namibie et d'Afrique du
Sud en la présence de la ministre de la
Recherche et de l' supérieur de la
Namibie et à la présence du directeur du
Muséum d'Afrique du Sud au Cap pourquoi
nous voulons ces échanges parce que
l'origine des peuplement à travers
l'esclavage c'est aussi
Madagascar le Mozambique l'Afrique du
Sud le continent africain de façon
générale mais je dirais que quel que soi
lesurs origines les esclaves d'où qu'ils
viennent on doit les prendre en
considération
à l'occasion de cette commémoration le
grand 20 décembre c'est un moment de
commémoration comme je l'ai dit mais
c'est aussi un moment de partage c'est
un moment d'unité parce que la réunion à
travers son histoire doit montrer bien
sûr les douleurs qui ont été vécu par
ceux qui ont été transférés qui ont subi
la traite des esclaves mais nous devons
aussi montrer que nous voulons constrire
une société apaisée une société unie la
min pour découvrir l'exposition mybr qui
a été officiellement ouverte ce lundi 18
décembre une exposition qui provient du
musée izico en Afrique du Sud de janvier
à décembre des visages pour décrire le
temps qui s'écoule le temps qui passe
les douleurs qui s'effacent qui se
cicatris qui parfois reviennent c'est
cela donc l'hommage que nous rendons à
travers cette
exposition commémoration a ce mardi 19
décembre à 18h30 du côté de la chapelle
pointue avec les cœurs de la liberté
suivront les rituels de l'enlèvement des
colliers aux esclaves la libération du
camp et le fleurissement du mémorial aux
esclaves